and now please welcome to the stage
youtuber Justine is Eric
the village in the book I talk about it
and here we are I'm cool like thankful
would you mind starting all of your
questions but it seemed like I just seen
so it looked like working on the film
how much it's been great so I'm hanging
out with magic dragons and we're in Las
Vegas right now say hi to the Internet
congratulations on four Grammy
nominations we're hanging out with Kevin
Bacon and you're promoting a new film
cop car cupcake everybody is just e now
a bottle on the show but she was
actually on the show once weren't you
Justine I was and I won the showcase so
best of luck
I know a puppy mommy we're gonna get it
we're gonna name is Matt I'm Maddie you
guys are never gonna believe this but
Maddie wanted the world dog awards for
puppy of the year and he wore a suit
next year he'll win Best Dressed if I
can hook you with Jeff Dean guess what
we're gonna make today no guesses okay
let's do this preheat oven
do you know how to work happens did I
not do this that is not a churro I will
give it my blessing well you look good
gentle pulls up there we go that's nice
let's plate a lot is this one here is
inspired inspired by choose day it's
Friday
it's a me Mario
piggy just in number one